now then the newly elected leader of UK
Paul Nuttall says he can win labour
voters over to his party it's a threat
of particular relevance to MPs in the
north of England perhaps where a large
majority of people voted to leave the EU
in the referendum a lot of Labour MPs
there of course I'm joined now by Angela
Eagle Labour MP for Wallasey who stood
against Jeremy Corbyn in the party's
leadership race in a very good morning
tear
how worried are you about UKIP's
performance so far under poor methyls
ambitious well nobody should ever take
their own safe seats for granted I I
never have taken my seat for granted I
campaign all year round but I think we
have to get this into perspective Paul
Nuttall it stood in butl as a
conservative in the council elections
this century and did very badly he's a
right-wing conservative he's on record
saying he wants to privatize the NHS and
get competition in which labour voters
are not going to be impressed by he
actually thinks that employment rights
are a waste of time and he said
maternity pay was actually mad and
counterproductive now and what is
exactly mad about allowing a woman who's
pregnant to go off and have her baby and
get back to work afterwards so you think
you have to have a bit of a policy
examination you have to get on the front
foot as Labour and say to people who
voted brexit perhaps thinking well you
keep at a better message than your
remain campaign in there that may be
tempted to stay with you if you're going
to say well look at their economic
policies look at their social policies
do a forensic examination of that and
that will hold them
I mean Liverpool actually voted 60% to
remain by the way I mean people it's a
more nuanced thing but but actually what
we've got to do is say we understand
that people are hurting in communities
and particularly places where they've
been huge cuts due to austerity where
people have seen their job opportunities
dwindle or they're working twice as hard
for the same money or even less we know
there's been a 10% fall in real wages
since 2008 so we've got to wreck
nice that but we've there are labor
responses to that that aren't about
right-wing economics and right-wing
social policies so you just three
without your gun are you going to point
those out you can put those front and
center the the other message from UK
well there are solutions to the housing
shortage we have to build more
affordable houses that people are modest
earnings can aspire to live in and go
and live in and then we've got to allow
them to have job opportunities and
economic opportunities to increase their
wages did you touch some house earlier
because we're being skirting around the
issue we have to cut to the quick here
and talk about immigration and I talked
about bouts of policy swap here and a
lot of people's analysis so for instance
pressures on housing are that too much
immigration that puts pressure on social
housing in particular and indeed the
overall housing stock more people equals
more demand for accommodation do you
think labor can continue with its
current policy on immigration well I
believe I have to say the first thing to
say in all of this is that not every
problem in our country is created by
immigration you Kipp would like to
persuade people that it is and they
always go to that politics of grievance
and division most of our communities I
don't think want to see us dividing
along either race lines or religious
lines they want to see how we can unite
as communities and make our society
better that's the labor would you defend
free movement of people's within the
European Union or within the new
arrangement that the UK comes to well we
don't know what the new arrangements are
going to be because you'd like to do
that well we've got a government that
won't tell us what their plan is that's
why it's important that as the brexit
negotiations go on we have some attempt
and and so far teresa may hasn't done
this to try to bring our country back
together I've never known people so
angry the 52% of people are on one side
the 48% of people who voted to remain
think they're not being listened to and
we've got a prime minister that sent
precisely the wrong signals out of her
speech in Birmingham saying that we were
going to go for hard brexit which
implies
an economy that's less wealthy and it
implies fewer jobs and fewer
accommodation that you know you've
examined the brexit vote you know what a
lot of that was about not all but a lot
of it was about migration within the
European Union would you would you say
would you say to voters because it seems
to be labour is still saying then we
will alleviate the conditions in some
areas created by these movements of
people they need more cash they need
more social housing they need more money
put into health and education and
libraries and all that infrastructure or
let's control it because that seems to
be the conclusion that many people have
come to nobody is against controlled
immigration very very few people are in
favor of completely open borders
everywhere and in fact when we're in the
EU what we did say was that there should
be a free movement of workers we were
never in the Schengen arrangements which
allow free movement of people we signed
up to free movement of those who already
got jobs and this quick pro quo with
that many many Brits work abroad in the
European Union do very well and come
back and there's that exchange in our
scientific communities which benefits
all of our economies so we've got to see
what we can do to bring about the best
possible soft brexit unfortunately the
current government are not telling
Parliament what is in their mind we're
finding out with leaks what different
bits of the government want to do and
it's getting more vicious by the minute
what Teresa may ought to do is come to
Parliament with a plan so we can have a
proper debate and try to heal the
divisions in our country make the best
of the situation that we find ourselves
in and get the best possible deal why
aren't you reckon Olympian for a few
which I've got to keep focusing on the
party is the Official Opposition who
were in government only six and a bit
years ago yeah
seem to be nowhere look at the Richmond
by-election there an opportunity to make
that very argument who made it the Lib
Dems well look I mean it used to be a
Lib Dem seat it was a very unusual you
losing your politics years fewer votes
than you have members well I mean
the issue there was about who could beat
Zac Goldsmith and most people there
obviously wanted to see get Zac
Goldsmith punished some because of the
disgraceful mayoral campaign he ran that
was racist and others because they
couldn't stand the fact that he had been
leave vote some opportunity for labour I
mean in the old days if you had a nice
entrance like Tony Blair oh I I agree
that it's painful when you're not
involved as a as a challenger in any
by-election but I think you have to
recognize that the Lib Dems held that
seat until six years ago and it was that
Goldsmith that took it off them they
were always in a better position to
squeeze by you win well look in
by-elections obviously our vote was
squeezed because our voters felt that
getting rid of Zac Goldsmith was more
important than voting labour in that day
you know he was told only six seven
years ago the natural party of
government politics is dynamic and if
you do not reinvent your appeal to the
British people and answer their issues
and questions then you're going to have
difficulties that is what we have to do
but except you haven't done that we are
in the middle of doing it we're in
opposition we now lost two elections and
we have to make certain that we go back
to the basic questions which brought us
into existence and we never needed more
now look at people who work they're not
earning reasonable wages a lot of the
time and a lot of the benefits of
economic activity are going to those who
own rather than those who work to create
the wealth that's why the Labour Party
came into existence in the first place
we've got to redouble our efforts to say
how do we create a society where those
who work and create the wealth can
actually benefit from a fair amount of
it that is the policy work that is going
on now for the Labour Party that is how
we will ensure that we appeal to more
than just our core voters but to vote us
up in that brings us to leadership you
know we talk about other leaders you've
been talking about the Prime Minister we
were talking about Paul Nuttall I mean
if you revised your opinion of Jeremy
Corbyn you obviously thought he was
pretty hopeless when you stood against
as he got better look I think in the
aftermath of the brexit vote there was a
great deal of emotion and anger the
Labour members have given him a mandate
and that is what we will work with he's
just made a speech in Europe saying that
we've got to ensure that we redouble our
efforts to provide labour answers to the
real problems and issues that are
causing the rise of the populist right
in Europe that is what we've got to do
that is that our historic role and he's
right to identify it and think about
what you said there about a lot of anger
and emotion did that cloud your
judgement are you saying it's that that
made you stand against Jeremy Corbyn no
I think there was an anger and emotion
about the brexit vote in the aftermath
of the brexit mention you were on the
other side yes how I resigned because I
felt that we hadn't and the Jeremy
Corbyn didn't do enough during the
campaign yeah a bit my comments on the
record of well-known but I accept the
democracy of the party the parties made
a decision we are now working together
to do that policy work to ensure that we
can appeal to the electorate up and down
the country not only our core votes to
see off any threat that you keep are
offering in our northern heart lands but
also to make sure that we can take our
appeal beyond just labour out into the
country as a whole because that's the
only way you win election what do you
say to those senior figures within
frontbench figures within your party say
well that we've got about the bullet
we've got to go for a Progressive
Alliance in seats that Labour can't win
by perhaps the Lib Dems or indeed others
maybe the Greens have a have a better
chance don't stand at one port
okay well remember let's stay with amid
tensions we may be sea we may be seeing
and it's some kind of realignment and
what about in in Scotland you know you
haven't just got the squeeze you've got
a three pronged attack on labour
heartlands what about a Progressive
Alliance is five Lewis is talking but
well I don't agree with the analysis
that we have to have a progressive
alliance in that way partially because
it doesn't actually win as an election
if you add up lip their votes with green
votes and you look at where they are in
particular constituencies I think it
wins as four seats or something
it doesn't do the job we have got to
remake our appeal to the electorate and
voters by talking about the things that
they care about most whether they can
have somewhere to live whether they can
have a job that pays whether they can
start a family whether their children
can have better prospects than than they
have these are the basic
bread-and-butter issues of politics and
that's what we have to the one person
trait on not adding up false bits of
votes that are not Tory and somehow
thinking that you can cobble together an
anti Tory alliance the only green MP in
the House of Commons Caroline Lucas her
main opponent the only way she will lose
a seat is if we have a labour seat there
that is not the basis from which to have
a Progressive Alliance but you know in
our stories in our system it's not about
the number of seats you have and look at
you Kip and there one MP in there there
four million plus vote during the
general election but a lot of those
votes cost labour seats they let other
parties else we all know that's the way
it works I mean you've got to go on a
full-scale offensive against that you
could vote and what we're seeing at the
moment in you Kip voters who say they
are switching majority of them vast
majority go back to the Conservatives
yes I mean you keep are a party of the
right and what we've got to do as a
party of the progressive side of
government and this is an issue giving
up on them you don't think you can win
them over you could vote no you kept
voters you give her a party of the right
what we've got to say - you get vertices
those right-wing approaches privatizing
the NHS thinking that employment rights
are somehow and nice to have but can be
abolished because they're mad to quote
Paul Nuttall that is not in the best
interests of working people or their
communities up and down our country
neither is the politics of division and
grievance which sets one group of people
against another we can only work
together and make progress as a country
now if we bring the 48 percent together
with the 52 percent and charter way
forwards for our country which is in the
best interests of our own economy but
the people who live in our societies up
and down the country you don't do that
by setting one bit of the country up
against another and I think it's to the
eternal shame of the
a party that they've divided the country
and the Prime Minister has shown no
interest so far in leading the country
to unite it in the aftermath of the most
divisive thing that's happened in
post-war politics and back to that me
for you you going for the hundred
percent then but you think Jeremy well I
like to well you know that would be
something that really would be Chinese
thank you well no I mean is an important
to processing tomography serious
question I mean is Jeremy Corbyn the man
is he at the van of that room does he
look like a unifier like a uniter look
I'm not here to have some kind of
commentary on how Jeremy is doing as
leader we've got to do this policy were
to be a bit of an open goal with the Lib
Dems it's back to we're going around the
circles it's back to what the Lib Dems
took advantage of in Richmond okay you
saying it wasn't labor territory we've
got another by-election coming up labour
and nowhere in Sleaford talking about
the Lib Dems perhaps taking that you
keep doing well labour used to be the
party of government are the Official
Opposition and you're not making an
impact well it's clear that we have a
big task ahead of us and I think it's a
task if you look across Europe the other
parties of the center-left have got as
well it's not unique to the UK in fact
if you look at the opinion poll ratings
of the Labour Party they are a lot
higher than the ratings of a lot of our
sister parties but it's clear we have to
remake social democracy and democratic
socialism for new times and as I said
earlier the key issue for us is how can
we create a society where those who do
the work and generate prosperity get a
fair share of it that is the question
that brought the Labour Party into
existence in the first place but we have
to have 21st century answers to that
age-old question Angela very good to get
your thoughts thank you very much indeed